moi je suis très embêté j'ai envie de
dire oui oui et non en même temps parce
que attention parfois les clichés c'est
tout simplement du racisme d'analysé
c'est à dire du racisme qui m'a dit pas
son nom
georges qui s'ignore c'est à dire qu on
dirait des choses sans s'en rendre
compte et en fin de compte on ne sait on
ne
on ne ferait pas de mal parce qu'on sait
que vous je crois la guerrière jamais
frérot tu as essayé de m'appeler toute
la journée j'ai une gastro de ouf j'ai
pas bien je te jure celle très roger
répondre à personne pas sympa sans kaka
n'avait jamais une activité de babel
qu'est ce qui se pa tro thierry técher
bien de voir ce qu'ils cesseraient chéri
mais je sais ce soir il sera et ce soir
et se passe un truc à sur canal oui mais
c'est promis non mes gars du jamel
comedy club après une tête c'est demain
soir sur canal+ premier gala du jamel
comedy club en prime time et le gala est
ouf
ce sera sur canal+ et chérie juste après
touche pas à mon pote ou vous bifurquer
direct façon un demain le psg vont
gagner on s'en fout c'est djamel quitte
à regarder
non mais c'est vrai ils vont gagner là
bas manchester city et le fluo match oui
oui mon chéri oui très bien alors déjà
moi j'arrive pas prendre le contrôle de
son attelage
ces toitures les phosphates est très
fort vas-y vas-y vas-y déjà commencé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vas-y c'est bon tu peux faire autre
chose ou pas je suis encore jamel de
m'asseoir je serai devant ils sont très
forts tu sais que tu nous manques tu
m'as manqué ça fait longtemps que je
n'ai pas vu et je vais envoyer bout de
la si tu viens pas me voir bientôt je
renvoyais bouder te voler des blues ont
[Rires]
déjà mais l'on vas te retrouver demain
soir sur canal plus et je devrais dire
diam elle qui a mis ce que je regarde à
la fois franchement la plupart des
humoristes ont émergé ces dernières
années c'est beaucoup beaucoup grâce à
jamel les jours et jamel en plus que je
kiffe et je peux le dire à jamel c'est
que le mec c'est pas du tout avec dos
d'âne parce que très souvent ils lancent
les mecs après les laisse partir
ailleurs
lui il veut su ce qui marche les mecs et
après ils sont mauvais c'est vrai je te
jure t une bombe et je t'aime mon frérot
et c'était c'est un peu juste
j'avais pas le maillage des gares des
citoyens et il est toujours derrière eux
ils les aident tout le temps et monde
jamais l'on t'aime fort et demain on
sera devant canal+
ça va cartonner il paraît qu'il ya une
entrée de ouf ne manquez pas le début de
l'émission il paraît qu'elle est innée
ou vous que c'est mérité
c'est mérité mondia mail en votant
brasse très très fort on va regarder la
bande annonce et jamel aux thèmes forts
et les sauterelles et son très fort les
hackers marocains
je crois que vous valez pas de bravo mot
djamel connaissent un regain